[Musique]
je vais vous parler aujourd'hui du film
The Kid de Charlie Chaplin
il a été réalisé en 1921 donc par lui il
a été producteur également il a été
interprète du film
on peut parler ici d'une comédie
américaine mais aussi d'un drame
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'on
part sur une histoire qui raconte la vie
d'une femme
qui n'arrive plus à faire à vivre elle
et son enfant du coup elle va décider
tout simplement d'abandonner cette
enfant
ne sachant que faire et du coup chaque
Chaplin va tomber sur cet enfant il faut
pas oublier que j'avais déjà pris une
joue régulièrement le rôle du vagabond
le vagabond qui n'a pas de sous qui
essaye de se battre pour vivre pour
avoir un toit pour avoir à manger et un
travail
il va concrètement se créer une relation
entre cet enfant et Charlie Chaplin
[Musique]
il faut savoir que Charlie Chaplin du
coup va lui apprendre tout ça toute la
vie il va lui apprendre
comment ça se passe quand quelqu'un nous
marche dessus sur les pieds
comment travailler comment
se battre pour avoir à manger le soir il
va lui apprendre la vie de façon tout
simplement pure et naturel
on a
Jackie kugam qui joue le rôle de
l'enfant
de façon juste merveilleuse tout chante
émouvante
on va dire même pure et avec
tout simplement enfin ancré dans son
temps c'est à dire qu'à l'époque le
petit côté visage d'ange pur
on le voit on avait juste envie de lui
c'est le serrer dans les bras et Charlie
Chaplin va faire ce geste là va faire ce
geste de l'accompagner tout au long de
sa vie et va avoir une véritable
relation père fils
voilà
chatine signera également la musique de
ce film qui va ajouter encore plus un
côté émouvant un côté touchant et ici
ici ce qu'on appelle une œuvre du 7e art
tout simplement
ancré dans son temps en créant encore
aujourd'hui
toujours aussi mouvante toujours aussi
touchante et
il va réussir du coup une fois de plus à
nous donner beaucoup d'émotions tout
simplement avec sa part de muet
un film qui pourrait se résumer par deux
mots
tout simplement une larme et un sourire
[Musique]